PSA test is the prostate specific antigen test. It's not super accurate. If a person was like,
oh my PSA test was 1.2 and then I went ahead and thought I'd get it. It was a year ago, it was 1.2
and now it's 3.4. That does not mean you have prostate cancer. It could be that you have inflammation
of the prostate. But if you have PSA test of 1.2 a year ago and now it's 140, you know, I have a patient
coming in Monday, his PSA is 1200. It's not fully, but it's not perfect. So you don't use the PSA test
to diagnose cancer. But if somebody's PSA changes dramatically in a relatively short period of
time, that's an indication there's something going on. That's completely an art form. And
a digital test is, if the doctor is an expert at doing that, you're not going to, you just take
a chance. Remember, cancer can be the size of a pit head and it's a million cells. So you're not
going to feel that in a digital test. So there's better ways to test for that.